time for a story you know following
millionaires venue
as successful people do guys i'm a
success of course i can follow
millionaires
venue 30k followers apparently
welcome to the one percent club helping
you become the best version of yourself
yes please
dropped a cup daily life-changing quotes
join us become part of the family
so i'm scrolling through for meme
material
like the hulk saying that classic quote
don't forget the lifestyle you promised
yourself
you remember when the hulk said that
guys so anyway i come across this
and i get a piss it's a wolf of wall
street thing it says it's all about
building the skill
the art of selling how to become the
best salesman now before i get
very upset and start screaming
incoherently
let me cut to the to the chase they make
an inspirational post
from the wolf of wall street but this
whole thing is like about how
jordan belfort had to to to rise through
the ranks
and this is going to be just like you
right about building the skill
the art of selling there's only one
problem though this is a movie about a
cod man and nobody
seems to get it
i don't know i don't know if this is
ironic i really i'm going to show you a
lot of evidence that it's not because i
know you're thinking to yourself this
has to be a joke
right they're showing a man who went to
prison for what he did a
farad and they're like it's all about
building the skill guys
this is an inspirational page guys it's
it's millionaire's venue okay top one
percent
why are you showing me a criminal and
saying oh yeah this is the guy you
should model your life after
look at this what this trade will do is
serve as a benchmark for future business
do you feel comfortable with me now
scott then you'll know this is like how
low
entrepreneur uh lifestyle stuff on
instagram has become
real entrepreneurs don't talk about it
right they're too busy working
the only people talking about
entrepreneurs on instagram
are fake entrepreneurs let's just be
honest all right let's do ten
you wanna do that excellent choice ken
let me lock in that trade right now and
get back to you in a few minutes with an
exact confirmation kevin
and welcome to stratton oakland thanks
man i'm gonna have a beer right
how inspirational guys ha hashtag
entrepreneur
look at these hashtags hashtag business
passion hashtag
business growth hashtag business advice
how about hashtag
went to jail how about stock fraud
none of that guys of course and that's
the kind of irony
about you know a lot of these movies
where they're like oh yeah it's a
commentary
on wealth it's a commentary on
sensationalizing you know these things
like i i feel like college kids can't
they don't know what a satire is
because when you look at the interview
of leonardo dicaprio and scorsese look
how they talk about it addiction
to wealth and power and greed uh during
his time in wall street and all of that
yeah absolutely this is a satire and
it's and it's a dark comedy
a funny approach to this but ultimately
what we're talking about is a very
serious subject matter the cautionary
tale of his time on wall street yeah
guys you know a cautionary tale now
let's go back to instagram real quick
make sure everyone was in on the joke
i will win it's so funny to me how like
wannabe entrepreneurs idolize movies
like this and then they'll un-ironically
quote
like coffee is for closers look at this
let them hate just make sure they spell
your name right oh when you go to
jail oh that's right sorry about that
celebrate little victories
they create the momentum that creates
big wins
you can't make this stuff up this cannot
be a satire there's no way i mean this
this actually if this is satire then
you're one level above my head and
that's what i get
i have to be successful because i love
expensive [ __ ]
boys you gotta commit fraud it's the
only way to do it look if you're gonna
be successful there's only one way to do
it
look drop out of college commit fraud
that's it
the only thing standing between you and
your goal is the [ __ ]
story you keep telling yourself as to
why you can't achieve it
actually that's not true the only thing
standing between you
and your goal is the [ __ ] story you
need to tell to your clients
to trick them into investing with you
guys right did nobody
understand the movie i i don't even
that's what it is i think people just
watched half of it like if you watch the
first half
i'ma i'm not gonna lie looks pretty
sweet
[Music]
you just forgot the last half if you try
and fail congratulations
most people don't even try hashtag
inspirational
hashtag criminal in jail let me tell you
something there's no nobility in poverty
okay it's not just one quote it's like
there's entire
pages of this stuff it's like a wolf of
wall street quote account
i don't know what to do with myself
looking at this you know it's just
seemed like there's just been this weird
form of entrepreneurship
that's just popped up lately where
people almost want it as a badge of
honor or something like i'm an
entrepreneur it's like
getting a starbucks right it's like a
step it's almost like a status symbol
it's like
yeah i've or i have an iphone right it's
just like to put on your bio
i'm an entrepreneur guys stay in school
okay
listen you're probably gonna get a job
you're probably gonna fail at
entrepreneurship and i know
that hurts but if you can't tell the
difference between
a con man and a legitimate businessman
there's a problem i think this is the
crime who puts these together and what
are they doing i mean it's not it's not
monetized right so how are they
who's putting this out there into the
world who's making these
inspirational jordan belfort pled guilty
to fraud and related crimes connection
with the stock market manipulation
and running a boiler room as well as a
penny stock
scam that's what i want on my hashtag
gravestone why people making quotes
about me
it's kind of dumb because i know it's
just a movie but dang that set me off
when i saw that post you know i don't
understand instagram i guess that's my
takeaway from this i'm a boomer who
doesn't get instagram and that's fine
don't listen to me guys i'm just uh a
salty boy a little salty boy over here
for no reason
society you want to listen to me broke
me or
a real entrepreneur like jordan belfort
played by leonardo dicaprio
that's basically it just be complaining
thanks for watching hope you're doing
well and i'll see you
in the next
what it one nothing but a trick trying
to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee